by the power of castle hate school i am
hella mark harley and we have another
special treat for you all today one of
my favorite fitness and life influencers
a lifestyle influencer by the name of
gregor gallagher ever heard of him
kinoboni yeah you've probably seen his
ads you probably know who he is you've
probably seen him beating the crap out
of an mma doll online that's at least
how chris deleo recognized him in person
he was like wait wait i know you
you're the guy beating up the doll
so if you haven't seen that check it out
but greg is a fascinating guy
uh he has a lot of really interesting
creative ideas about fitness and how to
get ripped in essentially the easiest
way possible so he's teaching guys
who are natty who don't want to make
fitness take up their entire lives how
to look really good and benefit their
lives in other ways too he's an
entrepreneur he has a clothing line he
has a supplement company
he uh he has a really interesting
approach to having a cool life and i
think you guys are really going to enjoy
this conversation let me give an
introduction
gregor gallagher kinobody um
let's see
i
now would consider you a friend right
because we've actually met in person get
over it haters um you know just don't be
jealous maybe maybe go to toronto maybe
maybe offer something to greg instead of
just taking all this free information
that it gives you around the clock 24 7
365. um
you know we first started talking
because you saw that i was wearing a
kinobody shirt on the front of the kid
i know i was like correct that's exactly
yeah that's exactly right i was like
holy [ __ ] this guy looks insane in keno
clothing yeah yeah you mean you mean
insanely good not like you know like an
insane person maybe both though
no yeah like insanely good i was like
damn this guy freaking i was like holy
like i was like that shirt looks
incredible on you um so yeah we started
we started chatting yeah and
one thing
that you said right off the bat that i
don't know if you'd like seen my post
it's probably just a coincidence but we
started talking is i gave you props for
the fact that
you have a lot of transformations like
whatever you want to say about gregor
gallagher
the proof is in the pudding as far as
you can post people who are like i've
stuck to his principles
and they go from
being fat or being soft or whatever to
looking really good and i think that's
always like a super important
metric to judge somebody by if you're
gonna go and i don't think you present
yourself as like a guru i think you
present
yourself as somebody who's like you know
has tried and trued techniques that
they've developed yourself
um and try to present it as simple a way
as as possible but
i like seeing that you post a lot on
your page and it's guys who are like you
know you have reason to believe they're
natty i don't think there's anybody
who's like oh yeah this guy's like not
you know and he's got like just veins
popping out of we're gonna gain 30
pounds of mass while dropping 20 pounds
of fat um
it just looks like a lot of guys who are
like normal guys and then you strip all
this body fat and add some muscle like
oh yeah that they look amazing you know
and uh and i've also i've bought your
programs
um
i told you i advise a lot of people to
do that because i'm like it's i like the
way that they're communicated i feel
like they're easy to follow and that's
another thing too because i think so
much of fitness is like
people trying to make things seem
complicated for money
yeah yeah you know what i just
i tried a lot like you know
i was passionate about fitness at such a
young age like a incomprehensible age
like i was doing workouts when i was
like 12. you know i saw my uncle doing
push-ups at the cottage with his feet up
on a chair and i was like that's sick
and i was like trying to like i just was
i was just enamored with training and i
started reading so much material and
i
kind of got thrown off by a lot of
different programs and stuff because i
was just like they're so complicated i'd
follow them to a t
and i started to realize like the only
thing that really matters is a are you
getting stronger on key lifts
consistently and you know b um are your
calories and protein on point for your
goal and like that's like literally it
and so i just kind of realized that
um the routines that i followed that
were more simplistic in nature i got
better and even more minimalist in
nature i got better results and then you
know the more complicated crazy hard
routines you think they're better
because you get more sore you're
training more it's all these different
steps and i got way worse results
and you know i've been so passionate
about putting programs together
forever since i was even 16. since i was
even 16 years old i bought like the
strength and conditioning um textbook uh
personal training certification of like
nsca or whatever and i did that one too
yeah and i i know i was actually too
young to do the tests i was 16 but i
just wanted to like i just did it for
fun i was like let me make like let me
just let me pretend i have clients and
just create these little workouts um
and you know i get really passionate
about
how do you put a program together okay
like a puzzle you follow it and then
week by week you're hitting prs because
you can put something together on paper
be like yes this is going to work and
then you do it and then you're not
you're not progressing it's like this
these little i found like these little
things like you get once you get the
puzzle right you just make
crazy gains and you're just getting
stronger you know and that's always been
um my sort of goal so i use basically
you know
if i want to build amazing body i got to
get very strong on my incline presses my
overhead presses my weighted shin ups
and then i just kind of i just kind of
pieced the program together that allows
me to do that and one little thing can
be off and i'm stuck and i change one
thing that's like boom the progress is
rolling again so i just find it really
really cool putting the puzzle together
and i love to be a problem solver you
know so if i get stuck i'm like all
right man it can be like you know we're
all gonna hit plateaus everyone's gonna
hit plateaus as you get more advanced
you're gonna hit more and more and more
plateaus sometimes you're very advanced
you can take a couple steps back and
it's like yeah how do we get to that you
know to that that next level and for me
it's always been peeling back the layers
and doing less and being more minimalist
in nature and training very hard and
that's the one thing people do not
understand about my approach they
haven't actually followed it wait he
only trains three days a week sometimes
i'll just lift weights twice a week
that's so easy that's so easy that's
sweet it's actually not that easy
okay because yeah if you like just like
you for example you're strong as heck if
you go into the gym and you do one set
of 120 pound dumbbell shoulder presses
you know for eight to ten reps or
whatever it is
that one set is harder than most
people's entire workout
right and that's
so
one thing that i really responded to
uh when seeing your programs and and how
you develop your physique and i would
you know first and foremost say
you are natty you went on more plates
more dates you looked at all the blood
work all that stuff to confirm it but
you know i i i have other reasons to
believe you're an added before that and
that we've sort of talked about that i'm
like you can observe somebody and kind
of be like a b and c almost personality
traits and that's something i'd like to
talk about
you know a little bit later like your
decision to not take steroids because i
think that'd be interesting but
as you're saying
the low volume stuff high intensity
that's one of the things that i think
it's hard to communicate with people
without getting to them in person is
like what does intensity mean if you've
never been to failure if you've never
pushed yourself all out on a set
um you know whether that shoulder press
whether that's squats or whatever
you start to see that oh you don't need
10 sets of of you know this heavy thing
and if you are doing 10 sets it's
probably because
you're
doing such a sub-optimal which is fine
if that's what you're going for but yes
i've found over the years through
experimentation as well that
high quality sets of of heavy controlled
work go a really long way uh i forget if
we've talked about dc
training because that's one that like
i'll send out to people like my own
bastardized version of it but it
essentially is a low volume heavy
protocol right and these dc training is
that the uh dog crap yeah yeah so it
mainly has rest pause but it like you
you i know do upper body lower body days
and that's kind of what dc is i was
using it in a three days a week format
and getting amazing gains and also
losing fat
as a natural in my 20s
and
it but it comes from like you actually
have to focus on those sets that you do
put in that work and go really hard and
i know you're also big into
measuring your pr's you know not maxing
out but going on what's my best for six
you know
right and
i i think i would also kind of consider
you
as you're talking like a mad scientist
you know like you didn't arrive at 13
years old with all the answers but
you've been through all this stuff and
you think about it a lot and
you do stick to the basics but when i
talk to people who are really
innovative and know what they're talking
about they know how to do the basics
well and then they also have their own
tweaks and tricks so i'm always
following you going like oh this is an
interesting thing during the pandemic
for example
uh
i loved what you were doing with
bodyweight stuff and i picked up for
example something
that i was just
uh with my producer case we had a
handstand contest i've gotten so much
better at a holding handstand position
because over the over the break or the
pandemic
uh i bought parallet bars and started
doing you know i could do like oh okay i
could do these uh you know handstand
push-ups i can do like 20 or more of
them just touching my head then you get
the parallel balls you're like oh i can
do two now because i'm going down a
little bit too but you're so much
stronger yeah even just doing two full
parallel handstand push-ups is really
freaking hard yeah yeah and i like how
you also have these strength standards
where you know it's like you know to
achieve this or whatever you have these
bodyweight standards that are
percentages of your weight um that i
think are really useful for people
because you can look at maybe the
strongest guy on instagram and look at
larry wheels or or whoever and get this
distorted notion of yourself being weak
it i think gives guys a really great
target to hit of like i should be in
this range you know and this is a lead
or this is average or you know whatever
and uh and i know that's also something
you've developed over the years like for
yourself
you absolutely like have to track your
lifts it's the most important thing i
don't know anyone that gets good results
without actually tracking your lifts and
recording you know i'm doing like it
just has to be tracked um it's the only
way to actually improve is like okay i
know i did x y and z let me try and come
in let me hit the pr damn i haven't made
a pr in three four weeks something is
off my program oh i tell people look if
you if you're doing someone else's
program not even my program and you're
get making consistent improvements in
the gym keep going don't change the
thing ride that way and you know but you
know i i say that but most people aren't
making any gains so like
right right right right yeah but
but no but seriously like if you
actually are getting stronger
consistently and maybe you want to ride
out that first six months of easy gains
and then you get stuck
that's when i love people to come to my
like come to my program when you're
actually stuck yeah you you know and and
the challenge is that a lot of people
they can get stronger on their squats
and deadlifts quite
easily consistently up until a certain
point but what they can't get stronger
on is
a lot of people hit plateaus pretty fast
on bench
and very few people get stronger on
shoulder press and that is the most
important movement like if you want to
just simply look like a movie star build
an amazing body the most important
exercise you get stronger on is the
overhead press it's going to build yeah
it's going to build up that shoulder
those shoulders that are going to just
make such a difference and so um very
few programs actually can get you
stronger on overhead presses yeah
and i like the that you brought up that
and the connection to aesthetics because
i agree
first of all
tell me how much you weigh
uh i'm i'm 180 and then like in my
content my photos i'm i'm usually
anywhere between 172 on the lower end to
180 right and so you know you're not
some huge 200 pound plus guy
you're natty uh you're very lean like
i've seen you take results that are like
five six percent at your leisure yeah
dexa like on the low end i'll be six
percent right now a bit higher but like
on decks i'm always around six to eight
percent and then you know if you know we
want to
give myself a little bit uh if you want
to add a percent or two you know i'm so
i'm always around you know seven to nine
percent um yeah
and my you know what again dexa scan
people look at photos and like again you
have to control for like legs and back
so i don't hold very much fat on my legs
and back so if i get seven percent on a
dexa someone might be like well you look
nine percent well you know most people
store a lot more fat on their on there
so like my yeah i've seen it like
someone that you know had
they got like nine percent of their dexa
and their abs were chiseled but they
stored a lot if you look at their dexa
scan they they're they're storing a ton
of fat in their lower body yeah and
that's more like me too like i you you
commented on that picture that i posted
my story and like i can have abs and
probably be like 12 to 13 because i'm
storing more of it my lower body and i
only bring your body fat percentage up
because again you've achieved that
naturally and you're not starving
yourself you know we'll get into your
diet model in a second but what i was
going to say is
you know you're in pictures between 170
180 pressing 120 pound
you know dumbbells for shoulder press
that's something that's like you know
just i haven't seen a guy your size do
that outside of you but it's something
you really focus on and then the results
are what you can see with your physique
and
i like i was just gonna say to
differentiate
your approach and what i found unique
when i first discovered you was like oh
this is a guy actually going like let's
cut all the bs
how do guys actually look good because
i'm a guy who grew up in the 90s and was
like
force-fed
like open bodybuilders like those were
like these are your role models in
muslim fitness they didn't talk a whole
lot about you know and you're of course
reading bodybuilding magazines but like
you know so that skews towards like the
guys are bigger and they're all like but
nobody talks about steroids either it's
a whole weird thing where you know
they're pushing creatine and they're
like 290 pounds and gigantic
i think it almost brainwashes you to
think like
and a lot of guys suffer from this it's
like i just need to get bigger that's
going to be the answer to all my
problems right it's just like more mass
more mass more mass
and
even bodybuilding today when you see
guys on stage or you see like a
bodybuilder
like in the off-season like
you kind of have to spend most of your
time looking unesthetic in order to like
be a bodybuilder on stage and whatever
go about that but you were one of the
first people who was like
yeah like i do upper body twice as much
as i do lower body because i don't want
giant chunky legs
you know i thought that was really good
i was like yes like you know but because
we kind of like shame people who like
skip legs but it's like you
i feel like we're one of the first
people to kind of go like no no no when
you see a guy
you know like brad pitt or on the movie
screen or whatever they're going for
these ratios in this certain physique
that's actually more attainable for the
average guy than to look like some
freaky open bodybuilder but somewhere
along the line that kind of got you know
twisted and i really like your approach
to bank no no no that's all nonsense you
know this is what the goal should be so
can you talk about that a little bit and
how you kind of stumbled upon that truth
for yourself
i think it's silly men getting this
sense of pride and i'm a [ __ ] man
because i can deadlift 500 pounds i
think that's i think that's silly um if
you can deadlift 500 pounds means you
can deadlift 500 pounds um so people you
know people get lost and like people is
this real thing that people get goal
hijacked um where initially their goal
is i want to feel strong and i want to
look good you know
be lean boom boom like i want to be in
shape because i want it to empower my
life better in my life enrich my life
obviously part of that is you want to
look strong and you want to be
attractive
um and somewhere along the lines then
guys get goal hijacked and then all of a
sudden like i just want to be able to
deadlift um 500 pounds or i want to
weigh 220 pounds or i want to get sort
of it gets sucked into this subculture
that takes a lot of it they get sucked
into subculture and all of a sudden like
they're kind of going in the wrong
direction then when they started um
i think like if you actually just wanted
like if if the whole idea is i want to
freaking feel like a man and be powerful
it's not deadlifting 500 pounds it's
probably learning how to box or learning
how to fight or doing some martial arts
you know yeah um
but
for me
i
i felt disempowered in the fitness
industry at 19 years old because
i wasn't training to be an athlete like
i wasn't a professional athlete so i
wasn't training to be that i thought
like the athlete training was very cool
i didn't like bodybuilding at all
i found it completely like they took it
way too far um i was not into like the
drug culture that was a part of it um i
didn't think that women inherently found
it attractive um i saw that you're
basically giving up your entire life
just to bodybuilding where you know
you're training so many hours you're
following this extremely restrictive
approach and i was like how does this
enrich your life isn't the goal for
fitness to you know i kind of want to
feel more like james bond i want to like
get in shape but like that's just one
little piece of the puzzle and i want to
live this awesome life i want to look
good and you know i just kind of was
like you know you want to like i kind of
just realized it's like
the crazy thing was that
most people most guys just want to look
like movie stars yeah and most women
wanted their boyfriends so they wanted
guys that just looked like they're in
movies movie stars shaped not massive
and bulky and cumbersome but they wanted
the guy that was lean 170 180 pounds
depending on your height you know if
you're
three it's you know you're gonna be
heavier um and
the craziest thing was this is how i
actually market my brand initially if
you looked at what people were searching
on google the most it was
xyz actor workout for a movie
ryan gosling workout for crazy stupid
love daniel craig workout for
skyfall and everyone just wanted to know
like wanted to look like movie stars and
no one was really talking about that so
i kind of like kind of that's what i
really focused on and so for me it was
like
and this was also probably why i wasn't
really drawn into you know i didn't even
for me i never really saw the benefits
of of doing drugs because
at 18 19 years old i've been lifting
since i was 13. i already had this
already had the muscle size i wanted i
wasn't like oh i really want to build
more muscle for me it's literally just
about how do i freaking lean down how do
i get lean how do i get down to eight
percent body fat um how do i frickin eat
less because i love eating i love
lifting heavy but it's like how do i
put keep myself in a calorie deficit and
strip this fat off um so like the
the the desire to do roy's never really
entered my brain because i'm like i
don't need more muscle i just need to
like get rid of this 15 pounds of fat
from 15 down to 8 so so that was always
the focus um the strength and muscle
came pretty damn easy to me if you know
how to train you're tracking your lips
and you're pushing yourself hard and you
have
solid genetics gaining muscle to that
level is pretty damn easy the hard thing
to do is actually get down to six seven
eight percent body fat so um that's
always been my my idea look like a movie
star like it's just the the benefits of
you know you do not need to like you do
not need to be massive you know just
like that's where you get the highest
roi
yeah that's a great answer and i feel
like
you know a few things i wanted to
respond
as you were talking um
i had that fork in the road too where i
was about you know like 18 or something
and and i was choosing between two
colleges one of which had a football
program and i was gonna you know
decide to play for four years or i was
gonna go to uc santa barbara they didn't
have a football team and they had a
bunch of hot chicks and i'm like in my
mind i'm like i could go to ucsb like
get really shredded and like just focus
on like aesthetics and i chose to play
football which i think that was the path
that made me initially i did a few
cycles in college and then went natural
from like 22 to 35 when i started trt
but in my mind there was still that
obsession of like i need to gain weight
i need to hit a certain goal i need to
like you know i like my goal was almost
like i want to look like a puffy power
lifter if i'm being honest with myself
um did you ever check your your levels
when what they were at when you were in
the football phase and then when you
came out off of it no but i know like i
definitely
like suffered from even though i did
like what i thought was a proper post
psychotherapy protocol um
i i know they were off because i'd have
like um you know even just feeling your
testicles at some point you're like oh
my god like but they would like like ebb
and flow it was weird but i knew like
something was off and at some point
after that i maybe did like a cycle of
hcg and like did a proper post like
years and years later but i didn't know
i'm just like a dumb kid getting you
know like sending envelopes of cash to
istanbul to get you know steroids in the
mail
um very reckless and haphazard but at
least i know from experience it's like
well you know i like to have the
experience of that and i try to talk
kids out of that who are that age but i
you know i just wanted to hear your
perspective because i think it is the
right perspective in most people unless
you're like super skinny
most guys that you talk to probably it's
like well your issue is you know the big
how do i lose fat here it's like get
leaner like get leaner everywhere
because and even
the first time that i got down to under
10 body fat i'm like oh i look way
better you know what i mean like and i
saw a picture of you i forget if it was
in a
marketing email or
that you posted on ig but it was like
you at 19. you're not fat but like
people might assume that you've just
been ripped your whole life
and you were portraying it as like
here's me at 19 and i just have like
extra body fat you look totally normal
it's just you're not sitting down or was
i standing yeah you're sitting i think
you're getting a tattoo yeah yeah that
one yeah um yeah there i was 19 years
old and here was the challenge for me
was that
i started lifting weights at like you
know 13 grade 8 i just loved it
consistently i don't think i ever went a
week without lifting unless like i
unless for some reason you know i
i was injured but like i was on it like
once i picked up my first weight i never
like it was just that i never like some
people fall off their program so i gotta
start back at the gym that never ever
happened to me i love fitness we're
training you know um but
um
wait story what was the question oh well
i was talking about when you were when
you were 19 and yeah you had a little
yeah a little more body fat maybe there
was a moment of realization yeah i don't
feel like i'm a fat [ __ ] now yeah so
that so as a teenager man being lean for
me was easy at 14 15 years old being
lean was completely easy um i you know i
wasn't like six percent body fat
obviously but like i just remember just
had like i trained a lot i i i did
interval training and some martial arts
and i lifted weights a few days a week
and just being lean was easy um i had
that desire to get big as a teenager and
so that just meant kind of bulking and
eating calories and that was sort of
like what people recommended was just
yeah get to eat calories calories like
it wasn't like no hit that perfect
surplus or just like just eat
eat and lift um and so when i started
doing that like i just remember like you
know i was gaining a pound a week
um and you know and in that in that time
i was like oh i could definitely i could
easily gain a pound of muscle a week um
and
uh which you cannot gain a pound of
muscle
yeah no i've been there before it's like
you convince yourself you know there's
another interesting topic it's like i'm
gaining this or even losing fat because
people who lose it too quickly or you
know you're stripping other things too
or it's just water but yeah getting an
actual pound of as uh npmd would say
contractile tissue
not gonna happen yeah i wasn't even
gaining a pound of lean mass i was
gaining a good a big chunk of that pound
a week that i did for 20 weeks or
whatever uh was fat um and so i uh so
then and the challenge was that after i
did that my appetite was like
huge and and uh you know it just i just
felt like you know i could just eat
three four thousand calories easily
easily every single day and so i started
to like tighten up and like you know
kind of tighten up my diet i kept
training hard x y and z and i just i
just hit this sticking point where you
know i just i was around 180 182 pounds
and i was doing training a lot lifting
weights a lot cardio kept my diet
pretty damn clean ate every few hours by
just like that was my sticking point and
in that photo i'll be honest i looked
better than that photo i was sitting
down so my stomach was protruding if
you're 40 body fat you sit down like if
i stood up flex my abs like i'd have
some abs but um again i was like i was
legit 14 body fat and i was working
freaking hard and eating clean and i
just couldn't lean down past that point
um
and so then that i went on a multi-year
obsession with getting to
seven eight percent body fat that was
become it was my absolute obsession i
was like i have to do it like that's all
i wanted was like i want to get seven
eight percent body fat and uh i tried a
lot of things and i i pushed myself
extremely hard and i just the the moral
of the story was that you know trying to
diet too hard trying to just cut out
carbs all of these different things are
not sustainable
and if it's not sustainable you can't
stick with it and i had very strong
willpower in the beginning i remember i
just i just used sheer willpower to get
myself lean once and i got extremely
lean one summer um
but it was like you know i built that
body on a you know house of cards like
basically just it was sheer willpower i
couldn't sustain it and then um and then
it's one when you go very extreme very
lower carb lower calorie boom boom boom
you don't have a diet you can actually
stick to then like it's hard to just eat
normally you tend to eat like like your
life depends on so i i so then um so
that photo was like before then i just
killed myself getting lean i actually
did you know i actually experimented uh
at one point with ephedrine caffeine i
think that's what i was taking when i
actually got really links it just caught
my appetite like crazy so you're not
natty
uh you know a bedroom yeah i used to do
a feature i would not consider that a
like a you know an anabolic star or like
anything even close because everybody
was doing it too
xena dream used to have ephedra in it
until somebody dies and they cut it out
but no i i
i wouldn't consider that not natural you
know what the challenge with ephedrine
caffeine for me was like
uh at first my appetite was like i felt
like i had like the appetite of a
freaking at first i felt like i had an
appetite of like six-year-old girl i was
like i'm not hungry i was like this is
like and so though i just started
getting very lean but the challenge was
a i couldn't sleep on that [ __ ] i
couldn't sleep and then
b
because i wasn't sleeping like on a fed
drink just wiped my sex drive i had zero
sex drive i just like i am someone that
just has a insatiable sex drive
um and then all of a sudden like you
know i i just it was gone and it was
like wow i have abs now but like i'm not
ever really in the mood that's like this
is complete garbage ephedrine and but
then also the thing is is that i found
and anything that really
suppressed my appetite and like i
thought you said i'd say probably
ephedrine was really the only thing but
um it like it
it only does it for a little bit and
then your body figures it out yes no
exactly you and you build the tolerance
pretty quickly because bodybuilders were
like like do two weeks on and maybe two
weeks of clenbuterol or something which
is another thing it's you know central
nervous system stimulant a thermogenic
fat loss agent but your body adapts
really quickly you can't just take this
forever and that's another broader
conversation of people always want to
know the thing that you can take and i
was just listening to today to a like
all the ways that you can lose fat from
i think his name is paul barnett but one
of these like he's a big bodybuilder and
he's kind of one of these more science
you know oriented guys so you kind of go
through all the ways and it's like you
know
tests growth hormone insulin leptin
ghrelin um you know appetite
suppressants like but like but it they
all come with a caveat that like look
you can easily undo this with just a
little bit more eating like you can you
know whatever benefit it gives you you
can easily come out of that and get fat
on ephedra and just not be sleeping at
night
if you're really devoted to eating and
so i really like what you said about
sustainability because i think that's
the main thing that anytime i'm coaching
somebody and they want like and i
casually coach people let's say i'm not
like giving up programs but i try to be
like give me five minutes i'll talk to
the phone and we could troubleshoot
because people want to know what is the
thing that you eat doesn't matter what i
eat what are you gonna be able to eat
that you can eat most of the time you
know because people think of it as like
i'm gonna it's january first and i'm
gonna do a month and get ripped and it's
like okay but what about after that you
know what i mean because you can gain
all that back in like five days um and i
you know when i read your diet model
um the aggressive fat loss system
i i feel like it's built for
sustainability and then when i see you
like a post pics on vacation or whatever
you're not one of these guys like i'm
getting shredded and then i'm gonna go
to mexico and just like eat you know 80
tacos a day and and uh you know churros
up to ying yang and get fat again
because
you can copy it on vacation yeah it's
all about have your like kind of cake
and eat it too i don't think happiness
is in any sort of extreme so
i think um being on a vacation and just
eating like a pig you're not gonna feel
that happy like you're gonna like if you
overeat you just kind of feel like crap
you you it's hard to go out and have fun
if you're just completely stuffed you
know yeah you're just spending most your
time on the toilet like it's not the
goal is not to like to completely uh
binge eat so on vacation you know
maybe if you're cutting maybe if you're
maybe you cut on like 22 say someone
cuts on 22 2300 calories yeah let
yourself eat 27 2800 maybe one day
you'll eat three thousand but
people don't realize how easy it is to
eat five six thousand calories if you're
not if you don't give a [ __ ] like it's
really easy people think oh yeah i just
was eating 3000 calories a day no you're
eating 4 500 probably um it's very easy
um but but um so on so on vacation it's
just like i just like to create a
framework where
i can i can get lean easily and if i'm
just kind of pushing the envelope i'm
just going to fall at maintenance
usually um and you want to be able to
enjoy your life so like i like to enjoy
my life getting leaner um i like to
enjoy my life on vacation within reason
and i don't like to have to just like oh
man i'm going to be on this vacation i'm
going to have to spend an extra cup a
few weeks getting rid of the fat i don't
like putting myself in that position i
just like to be like you know what worst
case scenario i'm going to eat
maintenance maybe a little bit above and
then maybe i'll have half a pound of fat
to cut off which is not really a big
deal but um yeah as far as the ephedra
story i just i just realized yeah this
this is not the right way to cut i
cannot use something that's going to
suppress my appetite make me not sleep
so i only did it for three four weeks um
but in that time i must have cut like
eight pounds or something um
seven eight pounds but um then it was
like okay
you need to coax your body lean so
i you know i so i stopped doing the
phedrine um then i i did but i kept
trying to do like these extreme more
aggressive diets i always just was like
i want to lose two pounds a week or
whatever and then finally you know i
just was like okay
like i was running in circles for so
long i'm like okay if i'm gonna get lean
i have to accept where i am right now
and i have to do it in a way where i can
enjoy every day to my goal body if
you've ever done any sort of really
brutal lower calorie intense dieting i
honestly think you have like you can get
away with it once in your life and then
after that you're completely burnt out i
can't even i can't even handle a big
deficit anymore like i literally can't
like i just i i burn myself out from
from restrictive diets that like i have
just
no willpower like when i was younger i
could do it it's just the only way for
me to get lean now is to coax myself
lean and that means you know eating at a
400 calorie deficit
fasting having a little small
5 600 calorie meal that just is like
strategically
satisfies me um then a big feast at
dinner that's like where i actually can
enjoy myself
and then chocolate at night and i just i
just found this little approach and it's
crazy like you know when you
like when i just did that i just got
leaner it was easy to stick to and
that's the most empowering feeling in
the world for anyone that's listening
right now like if you feel like oh my
god i love this diet i'm satisfied and
i'm getting leaner that's like the best
thing in the world that's what my
clients say like oh my god this is easy
i could eat all this food you know and
i'm getting leaner it's like the best
feeling in the world but if you're
getting leaner be like oh i'm killing
myself or oh i can't sleep or this and
that this isn't sustainable it's not
empowering in the least
yeah that's that's a great answer
because uh i i've always thought like
aside from these kind of media
representations of the biggest loser and
you have somebody like yelling at you
and that's an example of punishment
being via training but you can also
punish yourself via diet and i just go
punishment isn't a long-term solution
and most people just don't unless you're
david goggins or something you don't
have this like long-term desire to just
like destroy yourself to prove that you
can do it um and so
one thing that you said about a 400
calorie
a day deficit because that adds up if
you do the math to almost a pound a week
if you were to stick to that
everybody can do that and um you know
like and and if you split that even
between your diet and your exercise like
walk a little more and eat like half of
the thing you know like the snack or
whatever and that's 400 calories but
also one thing i picked up from you is
you do have a dessert
every night like either a high quality
chocolate bar or a rice krispie treat
right or maybe even both but that's
something that i picked up i'm like oh
yeah because if you get the high quality
chocolate it's more satisfying whatever
and as long as you can stop at one i
guess that's the trick for most people
is like you can
and people make this dichotomy healthy
food unhealthy food if i'm not eating
chicken rice and you know
i think you've been somebody who's
opened a lot of people's eyes to like no
no you can eat food that tastes good and
carbs aren't bad and i i you eat
potatoes for example and that's that's
one that i do likes most people don't
realize like if you're not overloading
with bacon and sour cream and all stuff
a potato is a really high volume food
actually it's very filling and it has a
lot of good micro nutrients but um
you're somebody who you can maintain a
very low body fat percentage while still
eating chocolate every night does that
blow most people's minds
it does um but
like i've gained weight eating very
clean you know yeah right i've also
gained weight eating like back in my day
like when i was 19. paleo dieting was
massive yeah i gained weight going doing
the paleo diet um
and then i've lost weight eating
freaking chocolate and potatoes um
the only the most important framework
for someone wants to get lean is
how do i make eating at a caloric
deficit every day as easy as possible
yeah so that's the only framework that
you need to look at for getting lean
it's like how do we okay i am i have 20
pounds of fat i have 100 pounds of fat
tools doesn't matter these are the
calories that i need that i can eat to
maintain my weight and this is where i
need to be to lose weight
safely and effectively how do i make
hitting this number as easy as possible
that's
the entire lens that i design that i
structure my diet like through yeah so
sure you know you don't have to have
chocolate for sure but
if i eat chocolate at night it's so much
i'm so much it's so much easier for me
to stick to my diet like if i you know
i've tried different meals and maybe oh
yes eat something healthy no sugar
whatever but like then i keep getting
cravings i just like every time i've
gone in completely shredded like very
very lean um i'm not as lean as i as
like right now i'm like you know pretty
lean but like when i get
very lean it's i've every night i just
finish off my last 400 calories with
chocolate
and
you know it's and it's uh you know it's
it just it it satisfies me like so
because i have a big option i can go to
dinner i can just eat eat eat and eat
and so like sometimes like hey you know
what like boom we hit 1200 calories here
let me just like i know i'm gonna have
chocolate later so let me just save let
me just i just get to look forward to
that like chocolate too so
um
yes some people make this sit like if
they just knew that it's all about
making hitting those calories as easy as
possible then they would kind of uh
they would you know do things different
um
and they probably do a little fast you
like
everyone should fast i just think it's
so easy to fast like if like if you just
drink some black coffee you can easily
push your fast three like three four
hours into the day and that's three four
hours where you're not taking in food um
and uh you know yeah you just kind of
you just kind of set it up and then and
then you know i try and eat like if you
if i really want to get lean if i'm like
[ __ ] i want to cut like four pounds
these next four weeks i'd pretty much
just try and eat the same thing every
day just keep it completely identical
like five days a week i'll just eat
identical it helps so much one thing we
didn't get into today that i really want
to get into with our next gregor
gallagher interview is nootropics the
nootropic that i rely on every time you
guys see me speaking into the camera or
listening to me
on your iphone
is happy hippo herbals and specifically
the kratom i use it i love it comes in
many different forms i want you to go to
happy hippo herbals.com
and use promo code fakeboy with three cs
and you'll get 20 off not just that one
purchase but the rest of your life
purchases so go purchase some stuff
another haters will say podcast another
oak and stone inspired outfit yes it's
the middle of summer yes i'm wearing a
button-up shirt that looks like it
shouldn't be this breathable and
comfortable but it is i barely feel like
i'm wearing anything but i look like i'm
wearing something something super
stylish and amazing and built with the
athlete in mind it fits great guys
if you want to check out these clothes
too go to
oakandstoneclothing.com it's a small
business with a great owner
and guess what
it's an american company that believes
in america america ever heard of it yeah
a little something called the fourth of
july maybe you celebrated it a while ago
aka a few days ago so go check out
oakenstoneclothing.com and use hella
code hella for 10 off at checkout
and just support the pod and let them
know what's up dude right and i like
that too because people
uh will ask me and i say it's just find
something that you can repeat every day
because it takes the executive function
out of it at the moment you're going
like what do i eat today you're already
taking a step backwards to potentially
binging um and then it just makes it
easier for planning it kind of like
desensitizes you to uh the like i need
novelty all the time with my food which
is a you know kind of a this conception
that people have like i i'm bored with
eating it's like well okay what about
just
you know okay that's cool but like
that's why you're obese you know because
you feel like you need novelty every day
and you need to eat out you need to do
all these different things and have
different foods every day or else you're
bored you know
complete garbage you know yeah
i eat the same every day
you get variety from you know obviously
you know if you're on vacation you're
going out here yeah mix things up you
know but um you get variety in other
ways in life you know yeah you don't
need this crazy different dieting but
here like honestly here's just the
reason here's the reason there's only
two reasons why i try to eat the same
way every day especially at first the
break the fast the last meal dinner i
might mix it up a little bit but the
main reason is a
it's just simple and there's no decision
fatigue it's just i don't have to think
i'm eating this so there's less room to
mess it up and secondly like getting
lean is actually really freaking hard
being in a calorie deficit is very hard
um if you're eating 2 200 calories a day
and you find this day of eating and
you're getting down to seven percent
body fat and you have this day of eating
and this big meal that just satisfies
you perfectly you don't have cravings
you don't have hunger you're always
satisfied
then
uh stick to that because you could try
and mix up different meals then you have
this dinner and like yeah like it didn't
hit the spot and then you're thinking
about food and then that day you kind of
graze on food you overeat it's like once
you have a day of eating that's so easy
for you just follow that like every day
like you can cycle two or three
different dinner meals um i know women
do not like hearing this advice
women
they do not like this advice but like
you know i know like you know i don't
know for me it's just so
just like
every time i've gone in the very lean
i've pretty much kept my diet i had two
different meals i'd cook at home
and then i maybe have like two different
places i'd eat out at so i had like four
different dinner options but like most
of the time i just kind of do the same
thing and that was it and like there was
no like yeah then once i got all the
momentum i was like you know you kind of
so like
fat loss and staying lean year round is
sort of interesting because a lot
sometimes you're like sometimes you've
been a bit more relaxed you know you
might be still fasting but you're a
little bit more relaxed you're eating
out here and there and then your your
weight's kind of coming up a little bit
maybe you're just eating a little bit
too much
and then it takes a little bit of time
to get that momentum to get locked in
get your calories like set
human beings were like creatures of
momentum okay this is why it's tough to
be in shape because if you're if your
momentum is
you're just watching netflix all day
you're grazing here you're eating this
you're not being accountable it's very
hard to shift that to shift that
behavior into
getting lean um and so i found that once
you're really locked in and getting lean
and you've got meals that are working
for you just
ride that wave and then once you get all
that momentum then you can then you can
actually be a bit more relaxed i'm going
to eat out here eat it there because now
your appetite has come down quite a bit
and so you can kind of get away like
i've hit points where i'm like i'm
getting like i feel like i'm eating like
a king and i'm getting too lean yeah
and but that's like it takes time to get
into that state and then i've had
periods where i'm like i just i'm always
freaking hungry i could feel like i
could keep eating but i know how to
shift myself from that state to like the
very
the lean state and again it's just
momentum like once you if you have and
this is why it's so important to be
eating at a 400 calorie deficit which is
why i teach is because
if you push the deficit too big
you will never hit that point of just
amazing momentum
okay because your body can handle 400
calorie deficit easily but if you're
doing a 700 calorie deficit or 600 or
800
then you can't really get momentum
because your body's deprived and so then
you're gonna you you know whereas
you know you might still be hungry
eating a foreign calorie deficit but
then after a few days your body gets
used to it you find the meals that keep
you full you find the structure you get
in the routine then you get the momentum
going there's nothing that gets in your
way because your body can handle that
level of a deficit um and so you just
ride this wave but if you push too much
training too much cardio
you know too much of a deficit then you
never forget that momentum because your
body's just in this state of of too much
of a energy deficit
yeah i like that because i also feel
there needs to be something inherently
satisfying and i don't think it's
inherently satisfying to just kill
yourself with like a crazy deficit and
just be hungry but like
that like i think fasting's kind of one
of those things where it's like
inherently like to push yourself a
little bit not where you're like oh my
god i can't think about anything else
but food but going just exercising
self-discipline in those little ways
on a daily basis it kind of builds your
self-esteem and self-confidence in a way
that i think you know it continues that
momentum it's weird because
there's times where i'm doing a 400
calorie deficit i'm pretty damn sure at
the 400 calorie deficit and the fat loss
comes off
faster
and there's then then it should i'm like
whoa i'm leaning down like like
sometimes i'll like my weight you know
and some of that's water fluctuation and
stuff but like but beyond that it's like
i'm leaning up faster than i should and
then sometimes when i've lost that
momentum i'm getting back in the rhythm
i'm pretty sure my calories are like
pretty close to be on point sometimes
i'm stuck
and then like people you will hit these
points where you seem like you feel like
you're doing everything right and you're
stuck
and then people are like oh i got to do
way more cardio i got to cut the
calories do not do that because um
you know humans are very damn it's very
predictable it's very predictable to
find someone's maintenance calories it's
it's it's pretty non-variable um
especially if activity levels are
moderate um and so
sometimes you're just doing everything
right and that like and then nothing
happens and then frickin you stick with
it and then boom the weight kind of
flies off sometimes you see like you
think you're doing everything right and
the weight isn't moving
um and this can be frustrating in fact
like i hear a lot of people that you
know
will say hey i'm eating a calorie
deficit i'm not losing any weight now
there's a short window where you might
not see fat loss because you might be
retaining water and that water is
masking fat loss and all and all that
but the only solution for someone that
is in a calorie deficit and their weight
is stuck is a you're not actually in a
calorie deficit um so
i i've hit this point so many times with
people where they if they go on
diets that are too restrictive they're
doing too much
exercise and too big of an energy
deficit
then what happens is
they're eating more than they think
they're cheating every third or fourth
day they're overeating they're not
tracking their calories correctly and
their body like it this is what happens
if you push the energy deficit too big
your leptin levels drop and you can eat
like no tomorrow and so your body just
like wants calories and so you can't
stick to it so um the best way to get
lean is again you know and again if i
hit if i am stuck it just
takes a few weeks to get that momentum
going and then the weight starts
dropping so the best way to break
through any any fat loss plateau is make
sure calories are in that 400 calorie
deficit
eat the same thing every day keep it
easy like keep it enjoyable keep it
simple get your 10 000 steps in every
day so you know that your body is
actually burning the correct amount of
calories um if you're sitting down all
day it doesn't matter if you do a hard
20 minute workout some people talk about
doing 20 30 minute intervals it does not
matter the most
the best way to lean down is just get 10
000 steps a day 10k steps a day two
three big heavy lifts each week
fast with your calories just easily on
point and it's just perfection
yeah that's a great point because you're
not you're somebody who's not big into
cardio you're not uh going out running
you know mile and after mile
and
you still maintain a certain level of
body fat percentage you know that really
again comes from walking right not a lot
of people believe that i also wanted to
say the thing about eating out of
calorie deficit um
i was talking to somebody recently who
was like i'm sticking to this there were
a woman who's like 250 pounds and i
guess she was uh you know not hadn't
gained hadn't lost a single pound after
following this strict diet
and i said well can you send it to me
and she sends me everything it looks
okay maybe a little bit low in protein
but um
i get to the seventh day it's like free
day and i'm like what's that free day
you know because if you're creating
whatever a 7 000 calorie deficit through
the rest of the week you can easily if
you if you're
got yourself to 250 pounds chances are
you can very easily completely destroy
that in the same day you know in that
one free day whatever right dude like 10
000 calorie challenges that's not a
challenge that's freaking easy
right yeah it's like
give me some cheesecake you know it's
not even that many slices to get to 10
000 calories um
so i i
you know
i think we could talk about the the the
uh the specifics of of lifting and
losing weight forever i wanted to
get into some of the other stuff because
as you mentioned before like fitness
being a slice of your life you know i
think that's really cool and i think
that
you
live that and preach that and have other
areas because you are a businessman
you're an entrepreneur and
um you know your vision i think for the
brand of kinobani
represents
you know not only your own creativity
but
you know as you've already detailed how
you can still travel and do and have a
life and not spend you know six hours in
the gym every day and achieve this
physique
some of your other
you know the things that you preach like
we can just have a general shift of the
conversation towards you know
what you think about
entrepreneurship and what young men
should be doing and um you know things
of that nature so that's outside of
fitness what are you interested in yeah
and just to finish off that last point
that's amazing you mentioned on the the
seventh day when i when you probably you
and you and me were probably interested
in fitness very early cheap days were
supplemented heavy it's like yup
strict diet clean and then you got to
have your cheat day and a cheat day is
the worst thing to do to lean down you
can do way too much damage in one day um
i
very was very adamant against cheat days
early on in my fitness youtube career i
was like do not do this like unless
you're someone whose idea of a cheat day
is eating like an extra freaking 500
calories which no one like people
struggling to lose fat that's not people
that are naturally skinny can do cheat
days because they'll go out and they'll
eat a couple pancakes and like oh i'm so
full i ate like a pig
so cheat days are complete garbage
anyone that's still teaching that is
just so
so off you know yeah
most people that teach fat loss really
have no idea what they're doing um they
have no clue like give me anyone in the
world i don't care what they're
struggling with i will solve their fat
loss in freaking 10 minutes um and again
it's not just telling them what to do
like it's it's half the battle is
getting someone to actually do it and
that's what i've like mastered in my
programs is actually that's why we get
so many transformations i've mastered
the ability to
to inspire and and motivate people to
transform and give them approach that
they love and they get sucked into it
that's literally half the battle um and
that i mean that's like pretty much like
the lion's share of it it's just if you
can inspire and get people to follow a
system that works
that's amazing giving someone a system
that works but people do not that has
the lowest retention is trash um but
you know but anyways um you know and
that's why that's also why i i laugh
when you know i there's a whole like
there's a fitness community the
evidence-based community and i was
actually very like part of that but i
just kind of shifted in the direction of
just i'm building my freaking brand i'm
building this brand i'm getting
transformations and the funny part was
that like i definitely got hate from
from that side of things and i i you
know i bifurcated myself from them by
being such a strong marketing force and
it's just funny because it's like it's
like guys you can't like
like you cannot inspire anyone to do
your program so it doesn't matter how
good your advice is if you can't get
someone to follow it you know
then you know and plus i'm in better
shape than you i'm stronger than you and
i have a sick lifestyle so it's it's i
like to i love to flex on those people
i know i love that that point because i
do kind of i probably feel the same way
and maybe even i was trying to think of
how i first encountered you um and i
think it was from somebody like shredded
sports science making a video trying to
[ __ ] on you because you know like it was
the uh the bruce wayne like dark knight
sort of if i'm recalling correctly a
marketing video
and somebody was dissecting like ah this
is so stupid and at first you're like hi
this is so stupid and i'm like wait
that's actually pretty cool you know
that he's doing this and being creative
um
and giving us something different i
think that's an amazing way to put it
that it doesn't matter how good your
program is if nobody's watching it right
or nobody's uh nobody's watching your
youtube and nobody's buying your program
and actually implementing it so
i do think that
you know it takes a lot of creativity
and boldness to come out and market
something especially when it's like
you're going out and saying yeah look
like a movie star it's almost like
there's a certain taboo even even though
we're in this aesthetic field um to just
say like yeah you want to look like this
guy or look like a hollywood actor or
whatever it still almost feels taboo in
a sense and um you know so i think
you deserve more credit for
both that the creativity and then
actually getting you know whatever
number however you measure like a
fitness influencers influence it should
be something like you you know you you
helped this many people transform but um
one thing i thought that was really
interesting that maybe not a lot of
people know
because you're portrayed you know by
some of these channels as like oh look
at this guy who whose dad is really
successful and he got all his money and
so obviously like the car must have been
paid for by somebody else but when i
listen to you tell your story that's
actually not the case right that your
dad didn't just leave you a bunch of
money
um he actually provided incentives for
you to hit certain marks but you started
making money on your own and decided you
know like hey i'm gonna start marketing
and selling this stuff online and you
know all of a sudden you're able to
purchase really nice cars but based off
just the success of your business that
had nothing to do with an inheritance i
think that's a point that not a lot of
people maybe know from the outside and i
thought it was really interesting to
hear because you know it's a great story
for a couple reasons the absolute worst
thing a
multi-multi-millionaire can do for his
children is to strip away incentive for
them
yeah
most
people that are from extreme like very
very wealthy families their kids get
handed
everything at a young age
um and i think that's wrong and uh you
know both my parents came from
very humble
like
backgrounds and they and my father in
particular
loved building his business he loved
working he loved like accomplishing his
goals and he wanted his kids to feel the
same so
they just didn't put us in a position
like i there was not a point where i was
like i don't have to work i can sit back
chill
flex on the broke boys drive lambo i
know that was never an option i never if
i want to do those things
i had to go and build a business and
make money so
people
have an idea of
the life of someone from a very rich
family
um and they have like that but you know
the reality is is that you know even if
i got handed 30 million dollars at 21
it's still impressive you know how hard
it is to have 30 million dollars and
then work your freaking ass off to build
your own business oh yeah right no that
nothing can take away the actual work
that you're doing which is um
you know to build a business to build a
brand that you've done it's like it
doesn't no amount of money
uh uh can give you the creativity and
drive and vision to actually follow
through on something like that but you
know what then you know i'll have people
say oh but you know what he he had a
bunch of money from his family to start
his business the funny thing was that i
started with no money okay i i i bought
a domain kinobody.com for 10 a year i
used some email service to to email my
audience for
like 50 bucks a month i hired some guy
that helped me just with my website like
it was weird i paid him like 100 bucks a
month or whatever and he would just help
me with some different little website
stuff i uh
youtube content is free everything was
like uh that was like the first year i
spent literally less than a thousand
dollars in my business
the first year and here's the deal um
most businesses
you do not like you can do them lean you
do not need any money to start most
business like if you're trying like
people are so like if you've watched
shark tank whatever you see these people
that just poured dumb amounts of money
into these dumb ass businesses
i love the idea of building a business
lean i'm very
i like i just i
i like to see bank i like to improve i
like to see my strength going up body
fat going down bank account going up
business going up and so like i just was
all i never liked the idea of
squandering money ever um i did it lean
and then you know after a few years i
got myself to a [ __ ] insane level at
24 and you know once i was just just
killing it like i was already making
tons of money before i even
spent my first like before i spent money
on ads
but the idea you just throw a bunch of
money into a business a bunch of money
into a business and then all of a sudden
you'll be pumping out profit
is very hard like if you build it lean
and mean it's already it's already
making money you put you then you start
putting more money in and more money's
coming out um that's kind of what i what
i like to do so you know as far as as
far as building my business i actually
like i started with my own money my
family was pissed off i dropped out of
university and so i like i had to like
kind of prove it i'm gonna i'm gonna do
this on my own and uh and yeah so i mean
that's like you know if i like when i
have kids definitely i'm gonna make sure
like they are you know driven to
to uh to you know
to succeed on their own
um i used to drive a mazda i was driving
like a mazda until i bought like you
know like i yeah that was like i i
shared a mazda with my brother okay grew
up in a massive mansion but i shared a a
mazda i used mazda6 my brother okay i
wasn't like so um
so you know yeah my parents were very
very adamant on uh on keeping us
incentivized yeah you have a great
interview with entrepreneurs in cars who
i talked to last week um and i think
that's another i would consider like the
fitness game this small slice you know
of being a man and improving in general
and then you have the world of you know
doing well with women and dating and
maybe you have some advice
um to pass on to to guys maybe some
things that you found counter-intuitive
or lessons that you've learned uh over
the years because we talked a little bit
about that in person and maybe the types
of girls that you go for and the lessons
that you learn you know having made
mistakes or whatever um what would you
like to say about that if anything i
think that there's a lot of information
out there on dating pick up chicks and i
think a lot of it is garbage i think a
lot of it just makes guys run around
like clowns
um i think that you have to look at like
the lens that like what is your goal in
your in your in your dating world like
it's good to like know actually what
your goal is are you trying to you know
are you like
are you trying to get a girlfriend are
you just trying to hook up are you like
what like are you trying to get like any
if you're running to the bar trying to
get pick up any chick in the bar
like that's to me that's like you know
it's like no you want to like ultimately
i think what every man wants is
not just getting laid that's like a low
level goal it's like a mat like what is
your dream partner what is your dream
girl okay like you know
like you want to attract
like that type of person like you want
to think about like your your dream
partner whatever um looks personality x
y and z i'm gonna track that but i think
a lot of guys just get lost just looking
at like just getting laid hookups just
numbers numbers numbers i think that's
um low-level stuff but
as far as
dating what actually works
being in
you know i was doing a video on this
recently but like it is such an
advantage to be in amazing shape it is a
insane advantage for three reasons
one
when you are in awesome shape and you
dress well
women start to look at you a lot they're
not to run up and approach you you don't
really get approached but women will
start to
gravitate around you they'll put
themselves in your vicinity they'll make
eye contact with you they'll want you to
approach them and so that is very
powerful you know if you are to approach
a girl it is ten times more effective if
she already catches eyes with you and
you have that little bit of tension and
so when you're in really good shape and
you dress well you walk like you'll see
some beautiful woman checking you out
and they give you eye contact and it's
like and you know like yeah if i go up
to her like she's she's into it um these
are called like they're indications of
interest um if you're in really really
really good shape
the friend zone disappears
there is no friend zone you're in
awesome shape okay and you you know you
just you're not you're never ending up
in the friends up and if you look like
freaking brad pitt and troy the girl
does not want that interaction and that
connection to end up in the friend zone
um and funny enough kino means in the
seduction community kino means touch
physical touch kino body is the frickin
about and the whole point of kino is
that
if you're just having a conversation you
could say the coolest stuff in the world
but you don't have that sexual tension
you don't have like that touch
then things kind of end up in the friend
zone and so with kino body it's [ __ ]
like there is no friend zone um and then
thirdly like
uh if you get freaking chiseled if you
get completely chiseled i'm not talking
about 13 body fat 12 i'm talking about
seven eight
percent
and you go on a little vacation you have
a swimsuit on you're by the pool you're
by the beach you just get that one
chisel photo you will just take over
your entire city on tinder and hinge
you'll take it over you will like girls
say like girls will say oh shirtless
photos are douche boom boom boom yeah if
every photo is uh
shirtless it's a little bit douchey for
sure i would never do that but if you
just get at one
that one photo where you're just looking
chiseled every girl is swiping right on
you they they they they just do it um
and so it's like if so anyways this is
like i'm just i'm preferencing how
important being in shape is it's just
it's ten times easier it's ten times
easier you know i when i was younger i
was building my business online i
dropped out of university i just worked
from home i wasn't going out to bars i
wasn't doing any of that so my only
option to meet chicks and i was not
going to be i wasn't about to go to the
mall and go and approach girls and spend
hours and wasting my time i could be
building my business my only option was
was tinder and i remember like i had one
photo at my like at the cottage i was
like i was anyways it's just i was
wearing my swimsuit my face was looking
down it was like a bad shot on my face
and i was just shirtless and i looked
chiseled and every like and i like my
daily life transformed overnight just
boom just um nut so i'd say
getting in shape do not delude
yourselves these pickup artists that are
or these guys teaching pickup that are
in bad shape they
do not get near the results of just kino
wars that follow my program got chiseled
no they don't don't get close to the
results sure they might approach the
girls it might be around girls but you
know that i i
nothing they're not getting very far um
and and for them to get far they've got
to put in so much work you have to be
chiseled it makes such a big difference
and then
the mistake that guys make mostly is
that they try way too hard
that is great advice to get the the
seven percent body fat and just take
that one picture because that's gonna
you know essentially solve all you know
you don't have to be seven percent
year-round but you get that one picture
that's a good enough motivation for most
guys to uh you know get in shape if you
can just do that and then that's going
to take you so much farther than
approaching cold approaching around the
mall for six hours a day um you know
it's a very as you're saying an
efficient approach it's a time-saving
approach ultimately and then you could
have a benefit of a a really nice body
at the end you know the challenge is
with some of these guys that are trying
to learn pickup is that they they're
just any girl will do for them right
yeah but if you're trying to like get
like really really beautiful women you
have to walk around the mall forever to
like see one and so i actually think
it's cooler to just live your life and
if like maybe once in a blue moon or
maybe you're at an event or you're here
or there starbucks you once in a blue
moon you see a beautiful girl and you
catch eyes with her you can just say hey
well
um
we're running out of disk space
otherwise we could probably talk for
much longer um but i really appreciate
you coming on i really appreciate all
the nuggets of information i encourage
anybody who's interested in greg's stuff
to go to moviestarbody.com am i getting
it right
yeah moviestarbody.com is my program on
instagram grow gallagher um and again
we'll have to do this again there's many
things that i wanted to get into that i
couldn't but you know you're such an
interesting guy and uh i love hearing
you talk about your areas of interest so
once again thank you for coming on and
let's do it again soon sounds good man
we did this yeah hell yeah talk soon
buddy hope you guys enjoyed that
conversation uh the only issue i had
with it it was too short we're gonna
have them on again we're gonna have one
in person hopefully there's so many
other things that i wanted to talk to
greg about uh
but we'll have to save that for part two
and part three
anyways tune in next week like comment
and subscribe if you like the video
and i will see you
next week